okay I'm not going to I'm not going to
talk much about politics today except to
say by the way I hope you had a great
weekend nice to see you again okay
that's enough pleasantries I'm not going
to talk much about politics except to
say that I think I can predict who is
going to win the Democratic Party the
Democratic nomination for 2020 and I
make this prediction not based on any
polling data or anything like that I'm
not even basing it on any qualities of
the candidate but just based on the fact
that this is the candidate that the
other side the Republicans are obsessed
with and that of course would be better
or ork as I pointed out many times I you
know I think he's gonna win the
nomination because of this as I pointed
out many times and I'm sure I'll point
out many more times in the future this
is the way it works now this is the
pattern in modern politics each side the
stars of each side are chosen by the
other side the other side becomes
obsessed with one of their you know
personalities and then that person
becomes an even more well-known and
powerful figure because of it so the
left basically made Donald Trump
president by obsessing over him during
the primaries he was the guy that got
all the media attention who's getting
all the attention from Republicans
they're from Democrats it was negative
attention but it was still attention and
he became president the right turned
alexandre o kzo Cortes into the biggest
star in politics right now by obsessing
over from from day one now she's at the
point now where we have to talk about
her because she has all this influence
and power so now it matters what she
does and says but it wasn't like that at
the beginning when she was just some
unknown person running for a
congressional seat in New York but from
the very beginning when she first
appeared on the scene the right just
latched on to her and once stopped
talking about it they did the same thing
with David hog turned him into this big
household name and so it goes and now
we're doing it again with better or
ork no other Democratic candidate
provokes quite so much focus and
attention and hand wringing among
conservatives which gives O'Rourke a
distinct advantage I mean look at this
tweet this I think this is the moment
right this this is the moment right here
when I knew that o Rourke was going to
be the Democratic nominee it was when
the the GOP sent this tweet on Sunday
look at this so you've got if you're
listening on iTunes and you can't see it
you've got it's a picture of a betos mug
shot from his DUI DUI arrest 20 years
ago or whenever it was with a little
leprechaun hat photoshopped onto his
head and the caption says on this st.
Patty's Day a special message from noted
Irishmen robert Francis O'Rourke please
drink responsibly now first of all it
just shows you what what thick skin we
of Irish descent have that we are never
offended by this kind of thing but can
you imagine pretty much any other
nationality if any other nationality
were the but were the butt of that kind
of joke like can you imagine if that
were a sombrero on occasion Cortez's
head and there was a little message
about happy Cinco de Mayo from there but
can you imagine the nuclear reaction to
something like that but you do it to to
Irish people and nobody cares ok that's
not the point the point is just that
O'Rourke has for whatever reason buried
into the heads of many Republicans and
he's living there and that means that he
is the most talked about and in these
days if you're the most talked about
candidate well that's pretty much all
that's needed to win and and you know
this past weekend Republicans were going
on about how you know this bombshell
news that O'Rourke when he was a
teenager was part of a hacking group and
they think that that's gonna make people
like him less but all you're telling is
okay so he was a punk rock hacker in the
90s like that just makes people think oh
you know you just made his cool points
about double or triple with that it's
it's just it's not working
this obsessing over a little every
little detail of them it's not going to
work and it's just going to make him
even more powerful okay now let me let
me step to the side for a moment a lot
to talk about today but I want to first
mention freedom project Academy look I
could be here all day complaining about
public schools in fact I have as you
know spent entire shows complaining
about public schools and I and I don't
regret that at all I have a good reason
to right now there are 50 million kids
in the system and the left is not trying
to hide the fact it made it very clear
that their intention obviously is to
indoctrinate the next generation into
their ideology and to do it primarily
especially through through the formative
years of a child primarily through the
school system so real world skills like
reading and writing and arithmetic in
American history well who needs any of
that right because now we've replaced
that with social justice gender
confusion test driven regurgitation type
instruction in the classroom thankfully
though you do have a choice you have a
real choice and that is why Freedom
Project Academy was created everyone
seems to love choice right as you know
we're supposed to show we're all
supposed to favor choice well here is an
area where you ought to have choice in
the area of education you ought to have
a choice about the kind of education
that your child receives freedom project
Academy is an accredited classical
online school built on judeo-christian
values for students in kindergarten
through high school
freedom project Academy has taken the
interaction of the traditional classroom
and it's created an online atmosphere
where so it's kind of the best of both
worlds we've got the that instruction
that you get in the live classroom but
you're also you're online with live
teachers in small classes who are gonna
teach students how to think rather than
just what to think it's how to think
this is about critical thinking skills
that should be the objective with
education so go to freedom for school
comm and request a free information
packet today that's freedom for school
comm enroll by March
thirty first to take advantage of the
best early bird discount so you have a
couple of weeks left but go right now
and don't forget to subscribe to their
weekly podcast the dr. Duke show
available on iTunes and more take back
control of your kids education freedom
for school comm freedom for school comm
freedom for school dot-com alright Nancy
Pelosi had a press conference late last
week and here's an interesting exchange
listen to this well I disagree with the
ACLU on this the in terms of legislation
we couldn't be prouder than HR 1 this is
about reducing the role of big dark
special interest money in politics and
empowering small donors it's about
ending voter suppression it's about
making redistricting fair it's it's it's
really a source of joy and hope to so
many people in the country I myself
personally I'm not speaking for my
caucus I myself have always been for
lowering the voter to voting age to 16 I
think it's really important to capture
kids when they're in high school when
they're interested in all of this when
they're learning about government to be
able to vote that is that is not enough
to sit in other words some of the
priorities in this bill or that
transparency and openness and
accessibility and the rest that's a
subject of debate but my view is that I
would welcome that but I've been in that
position for a long time so she wants to
capture kids in high school capture what
didn't what an apt word choice and
notice the gesture she made while she's
a so we got to capture them capture them
she made this gesture like she wanted to
grab them by the throat and drag them
into the polling booth without with
which I which I'm sure she would she
would do if we let her do it this is an
idea that is becoming increasingly
popular among Democrats a Democrat as it
was
being alluded to in the clip I just
played a Democrat proposed an amendment
to the bill that Pelosi was talking
about an amendment that would allow 16
year-olds to vote it would lower the
voting age 16 and it was 120 some
Democrats signed on to the idea so this
is something that I suspect as time goes
on will become even more popular among
Democrats why why would a Democrat want
16 year-olds to vote well obviously
because 16 year-olds are more likely to
vote Democrat and Republican but what
does that tell you right what does that
tell you about the Democrat Party that
they're saying well we got to get in and
capture them while they're young because
if we wait too long you know by the time
they grow up and get a little bit older
they might not be Democrats anymore so
what does that tell you about about the
leftist ideology and what the Democrats
are pushing that a person is much more
likely to support it when they're 16
than they are when they're like 36 and
they have a family and they've lived you
know they've they've lived a little bit
they've had some experience and they've
grown and gotten wiser they're less
likely to support it well you know what
it tells you that the leftist ideology
is among other things silly and childish
and ridiculous
so what about allowing 16 year-olds
because because you know although that's
the case I also don't think I think it's
it's of course ethically wrong to
support you know expanding the voting
age just because you think it will help
your political party which is what all
these Democrats are doing but at the
same time it would also be ethically
wrong to oppose expanding the voting age
just because you think it will hurt your
favorite political party you got to have
a better reason than that and I I think
we do have a pretty good reason for not
sixteen year olds to vote and that is
well first of all sixteen year olds have
no it's not just that they haven't lived
very long and they don't have that
experience in that wisdom they have no
responsibility okay that they they don't
have any skin in the game
they're almost every sixteen year old is
still going to be living at home with
their parents most of them don't have
jobs hardly any of them are gonna have
full-time jobs they're not paying bills
they're not doing they're just living at
home and see the idea with voting is it
supposed to be people who actually have
skin in the game and have something to
lose and so they're going in and they
get a voice but when you give a voice to
people who have who haven't really
nothing to lose because they you know
they're not really paying any taxes they
have no responsibilities most of the
laws that are passed don't really affect
them directly well that's a big problem
and of course you could point out that
well yeah a lot of a lot of eighteen
year olds don't have any skin in the
game and and are still living in a lot
of a lot of 23 year olds well yeah
that's true which is why if we're gonna
do anything with the voting age we
should be moving it back some the idea
originally with voting was the idea that
our founders had was well we're gonna
let landowners vote because these are
the people who are really contributing
and these are the people who are going
to be most affected by the laws now
obviously that had the not unintentional
effect of disenfranchising all black
people all women at that time which
which which of course was wrong
but now it's we don't discriminate in
the voting booth based on gender or race
so which which is great so now matter
what your race is matter what genders
you can vote so we're all on the same
page there but I think that means we can
go back now and sort of and look at some
of those ideas and maybe adopt a few of
them now that we've taken the racist and
sexist angles out of it so that's great
but is there something to be said for
the idea of only letting people vote if
they are contribute
members of society well there's nothing
to be said for it if you have entire
races and genders who are not allowed to
contribute to sight but as long as
everyone's allowed to contribute then I
think we could say well if you're not a
contributing member maybe you shouldn't
be voting and especially at sixty like
when you here's the thing about sixteen
when you reach sixteen that is when you
first when you really start to enter
into what I would call peak dumb face
that is when you when you start to enter
into your phase especially if you're a
guy where you were going to be your
dumbest and most reckless self and
you're gonna stay at that phase in fact
you're gonna keep climbing for a little
bit and you'll you'll hit really the
zenith probably around these days you
know maybe 22 or 23 and then you'll
start a very slow descent into maturity
but I think the idea is probably it's
best to keep people out of the voting
booth for as long as possible while
they're in that phase although I will
say this although I think it's crazy to
allow sixteen year olds to vote I would
be okay with it I would support it I
would support allowing sixteen year olds
to vote and in fact I would say let's
even we could even lower the voting age
to twelve for all we can lower it to
seven for all I care if all voters were
required as I have suggested in the past
if all voters were required to take a
simple civics test just confirming that
they have a basic rudimentary
understanding and knowledge of the
system in which they are participating
if we required everyone of all ages to
take that test in order to vote then I
would say fine you know what we don't
even need a voting age if you've got a
toddler who can pass that test then
absolutely let them vote I'd rather have
that toddler voting than then I mean the
majority of four-year-olds who vote
these days so if we wanted to go that
route I'd be all for it but of course of
course we're not so it's a terrible idea
all right here's this
but else I wanted to talk about taking a
step back from politics or anything like
that I have been I have been known to
criticize Christian films generally I
find the offerings of the faith-based
genre to be exploitative emotionally
manipulative shallow theological II
suspect and embarrassing on a number of
levels the bad acting and and the bad
writing would be perhaps a surmountable
problem if it were actually true that as
people sometimes claim the people who
make these movies have their hearts in
the right place you know it's it's it's
well-intentioned but I think in many
cases the thing that really bothers me
about the Christian entertainment is
that I don't think it's well-intentioned
and I don't think the people who make
these things do have their hearts in the
right place unless the right place is
their wallet because I think that's what
they're focused on there's a lot of
money to be made in Christian
entertainment because it caters to an
audience that will consume literally
anything that carries the Jesus tag
there is a there's a a large audience of
there are millions of people out there
who they have no standards that no
artistic standards whatsoever no
standards in terms of quality if but if
it's even if it is faith-based if it's
Christian I'm doing the scare quotes way
too much I gotta just well I'll put the
scare just you can do the scare quotes
in your mind every time I use the phrase
Christian entertainment from here on out
but there are people that as long as it
has that tag on it they will consume it
which means that it's a very profitable
industry to be in because there's no
need to spend money and time producing
something with emotional intellectual
depth theological insight artistic value
what-have-you you don't need to do that
just hit the right notes
repeat the right lines pander in the
right way and you'll make millions of
dollars I don't think this is a good
state of affairs it isn't good because
for two reasons number one it makes
Christians look shallow to the rest of
the world
and worse it makes Christians actually
become shallow because their religious
and philosophical ideas are being shaped
by the empty rhetoric they get from
Christian movies and and and even a lot
of Christian music now so I say all this
many Christians will agree with with
what I've said so far for the most part
they'll agree but then they'll insist
that well there are some good ones right
there are Christian movies who are who
are that are that are actually good that
are high-quality and generally the
movies that tend to make it into the
good ones category our movies like well
The Passion of the Christ which is not
only good but great the movie risen I
can only imagine came out you know just
last year the case for Christ a few
others and as I said a Passion of Christ
is legitimately great the other ones
I've seen most of them they're pretty
good they're decent not not great but
but but okay
another film that has often been
suggested to me as a good ones candidate
is the movie God's not dead and there
are now I think I think there are three
films in the god's not dead Cinematic
Universe as they as I sort of pop up
every spring around Easter time like
dandelions now the original starring
Kevin Sorbo came out in 2014 and it's
been recommended to me periodically and
sometimes very enthusiastically over the
last five years with a Christians
insisting to me that it is actually one
of the good ones and I've even been told
many times that it is a it's a it's a
good it's an effective apologetic tool
is this movie so finally although in
five years late I decided to watch the
movie over the weekend and
it was much much worse than I could have
ever imagined it was possibly the most
torturous thing that any Christian has
ever contrived at least since the
Inquisition but God's not dead so
perfectly encapsulates everything wrong
with Christian entertainment with the
Christian entertainment industry that at
various points in the film I really
thought that maybe it was a parody like
I really had to stop and think was a is
this real is this a this has got to be
some kind of satire you could actually
make a movie you could make you could
make that movie into a hilarious parody
of Christian films and you wouldn't have
to change a single scene or a single
line of dialogue you just it's if you
wanted to make a parody of God's not
dead well it would just be God's not
dead it would just be that movie done
over again and when I say it's bad it's
not just bad in the sense of being hokey
although it is that or in the sense of
being poorly scripted importantly acted
although it is that as well but it's bad
in the sense of being actively harmful
because it does so much insulting and
demeaning and demonizing and exploiting
and it does it all beneath this jesusí
veneer which is what christian movies
very often do and so it's for that
reason that although I'm five years late
I thought it might be worthwhile to
examine just what makes this particular
movie so malignant because I think that
this movie as I said kind of
encapsulates everything that's wrong
with Christian entertainment so let me
give you a quick review of this if you
haven't seen the movie before I
summarize the plot of God's not dead
I'll begin with a quick disclaimer that
I'm not going to bother naming any of
the characters in the film when I talk
about it I won't I won't give you their
names and I won't bother giving them
their names because the filmmakers
didn't bother giving these characters
anything in the way of personality or
motivation or believable dialogue so
they're all just caricatures they're
archetypes you've got the the earnest
Christian student
the grumpy atheist professor the ditzy
secular girlfriend the bratty liberal
blogger the wise pastor the
self-absorbed atheist lawyer the
fundamentalist Muslim father the all
kinds of characters like that we also
get a kid we get a cameo appearance from
cool black guy who and I swear I'm not
making this up but there's a scene where
you've got this black student who
introduces himself as G dog that I
actually I had to stop the movie move
movie on my computer at that moment and
just collect myself and say did that act
yeah that really happened they they they
actually put that scene into the movie
the one black guy that appears in the
movie and his name is G dog and then
there's also the slacker classmate in a
ball cap who he just appears in one
scene but it was a great show where my
favorite scenes in the movie when the
professor on the first day of class the
grumpy atheist professor comes out and
he gives us a little spiel about how
it's gonna be a tough class and he says
he says you know this isn't just an it
couldn't be an easy a you're gonna have
to work hard in this class and then the
slacker student goes I'm not I'm not
kidding the slacker said it goes I'm out
of here
then he gets up and he leaves the
classroom and and then they didn't show
this part but then I assume he
skateboards down to the local park and
spray-paints school sucks on the
halfpipe you know I I they didn't show
it but I think we're supposed to fill in
those blanks so needless to say every
atheist in the film is selfish and
miserable every Christian is
well-adjusted and generous and cheerful
and nice there are no shades of gray and
these characters or whatsoever
at one point the the eighth the the
atheist lawyer is at dinner with his
bratty liberal blogger girlfriend and
she tells him that she has cancer and so
the atheist lawyer his response is this
couldn't wait till tomorrow and and then
he respond and then he lectures her for
ruining his day and then he dumps her on
the spot forget
cancer and you know what that was
actually one of the subtler scenes in
the film that was that was actually
maybe the most nuanced scene in the
entire movie was that
so the basic plot revolves around the
struggle between earnest Christian
student ECS for short and grumpy atheist
professor or a JP gap so on the first
day gap requires all students to write
the phrase God is dead on a sheet of
paper and sign it and they're supposed
to do this gap explains because God is
lame and stupid and religion is dumb and
so that's why they have to do this and
so he gives this assignment and of
course he passes up paper all the
students in the class are prepared to
immediately sign this pledge swearing
off God for all time except for earnest
Christian student you know he has a he
has a bit of a moral crisis and he takes
a brave stand and says I'm not gonna
sign the paper because I'm earnest and
Christian and so grumpy atheist
professor tells them that okay well if
you don't want to sign the paper you
don't have to but that means that you're
gonna have to prove that God exists or
you'll fail the class this is all very
realistic right this is how it really
goes I've never been to college but I
admit I didn't go to college myself
maybe this is that how the classes
actually work I don't know I tend to
doubt it
so he's given this assignment that he
has to over the next few weeks prove
that God exists or he'll fail the class
so after researching the the the
question and praying for it a little
praying a bit and I'm getting a little
bit of a pep talk from the wise pastor
character he finally comes up with three
arguments for the existence of God which
he presents in three separate scenes
dispersed throughout the film he argues
first that God exists because the
universe had a beginning second that God
exists because of the diversity of life
and the suddenness with which it came
into existence and 30 argues that God
exists because without God there are no
moral absolutes so the first two
arguments as given are among the weakest
in the theistic arsenal I think yet the
Atheist professor has
no response for them whatsoever he is
completely flummoxed by them he has no
respite you can't think of a single
response when when the Christian student
says that the creation account in
Genesis was vindicated by Big Bang
Theory the grumpy atheist professor
somehow didn't think to observe that
well yeah but Genesis has the earth
pre-existing the universe which is not a
sequence of events that modern cosmology
confirms which I would say is a point
that we as Christians can deal with but
it's not a point that the movie had any
interest in dealing with whatsoever so
instead the Atheist professor has no
response except to Jess eh oh yeah well
Stephen Hawking is an atheist and then
he storms out of the room and that's the
end of that exchange and then so he
makes the argument about the the the
life coming onto the scene so quickly
and the Atheist professor has no
response to that except to quote the
book of Job and then to admit that he is
only an atheist because his mom died of
cancer and he has no other responses
finally the Christian student wins the
argument and the day by shouting well he
makes the moral arguments as well there
are no moral absolutes again the Atheist
professor has no response to that now
this is this is supposed to be ate this
is supposed to be a philosophy professor
who has no response for the moral
argument for the existence of God which
is an argument that if you talk to
Christians it's a good argument I think
Christian Aaron so we bring it up all
the time it's an argument that every
atheist has a response to because they
hear it so often yet this atheist had no
response to it finally the Christian
student wins wins the day by shouting at
his professor why do you hate God he
shots at Adam like three times and
finally the professor breaks it's
supposed to be I guess they kind of a
few good men scene where the professor
breaks down it admits that yes I I know
that God exists but I hate him because
he took my mother from me and then a few
scenes later the professor gets run over
by a car on his way to a Christian rock
concert and lies there in the rain with
the wise pastor kneeling over him
praying
and the the Atheist professor comes to
Jesus in that moment with his dying
breath and that's the end of the movie
remarkably the movie leaves the
strongest theistic arguments on the
cutting room floor it never mentions the
fine-tuning argument or the argument
from consciousness which I think are
very strong the cosmological argument is
given a very weak showing the argument
about the origins of life is also framed
in a very weak way and then and
meanwhile the Atheist side was presented
as being entirely bereft of any logical
reasoning whatsoever
the it's it's presented as if atheists
have no arguments at all on their side
they they have nothing the Atheist
professor even allowed the Christian
student to neutralize the problem of
suffering by bringing up free will which
free will is part of the answer but if
an atheist brings up the problem of
suffering to you and you say free will
well what's their next move gonna be
they're gonna say okay yeah but what
about cancer and earthquakes what does
freewill have to do with that and but
this atheist this particular atheist
although he's a philosophy professor
never thought to bring up that point the
student just brought up through free
will and the professor said okay yep
well you win that point this is a
there's one of the scene I like to have
to mention um the the bratty liberal
blogger confronts one of the guys from
duck dynasty who of course appears in
the movie because obviously he's gonna
appear in a movie like this and she she
says she tells him that she's offended
that he openly prays to Jesus so much
and then he has this very eloquent
response ready for it but once again yes
it's it's perfectly believable that in a
that a liberal blogger would confront
someone from duck dynasty but there the
liberal blogger isn't going to say I am
offended that you pray to Jesus what
she's going to say is
he's gonna bring up homophobia and
accuse you of being homophobic and and
that's the tact that she's gonna take
but in this movie she doesn't bring that
up because every atheist in this movie
always presents the weakest possible
version of their argument and does so in
the stupidest imaginable way so what's
the point of a movie like this it's not
a good primer for Christian apologetics
because it sets the best apologetic
arguments to the side and it also
studiously avoids all of the
intellectual and theological challenges
for which a Christian might need to be
prepared now sure if a liberal ever
tells you that they're offended that you
pray to Jesus or if an atheist ever
argues his case by shouting Stephen
Hawking at you five times and then
storming out of the room in tears yeah
you'll be well prepared for that
confrontation if you saw this movie but
then again you don't need to be equipped
for a confrontation like that because
it's fictional and that's not the way it
goes in real life as for real
discussions and real challenges this
movie has absolutely nothing to offer
whatsoever so what what is the plan you
know what what's the movie like this
trying to achieve it's also not going to
help you understand the other side
because in this film the other side is
exclusively populated by psychotic
brain-damaged narcissists with with IQs
of about 45 so it's not gonna help you
with that and it won't help you better
understand the difficulties of living a
Christian life because Christians in
this in this movie have no difficulties
they're all happy satisfied smart
attractive well-adjusted well-spoken
supremely confident in their faith at
all times although everyone does seem to
get cancer in the end but aside from
that it is a it's a it's a it's you know
Christians are just wonderful and
amazing and awesome and if you think
that's the way it is in reality we'll
just take one step inside a real church
in real life and you will be disabused
of that notion rather quickly because
Christians are also very flawed troubled
broken people as well
so then what is the point is the
question as far as I can tell this move
is basically spiritual pornography it
exists first to turn a profit and second
to make Christians feel good in the
cheapest and most debasing manner
possible you are meant to walk out of
the movie not with wisdom or
understanding or knowledge or
information or edification or anything
like that but with an entirely empty
satisfaction and with that sort of sick
feeling of superiority that you always
get when you set up a straw man and burn
it to smithereens which is all this
movie does and it does so with such
cynicism that IIIi really hate it it's
really just a garbage trash worthless
awful movie in every way and I really
would encourage Christians to reject
garbage like this read Dostoevsky
instead okay The Brothers Karamazov
Dostoevsky is a devout Russian Orthodox
but in that movie he makes his atheist
character a brilliant layered tragic
nuanced interesting figure who presents
some of the most compelling arguments
against God that you will ever read
anywhere some of the most compelling
arguments against God you will ever read
are in that book which is a Christian
book written by a Christian but he
confronts that the hardest arguments
that an atheist can possibly present and
he faces those arguments down and he
comes up with some kind of it not a
perfect answer because there is no
perfect but he comes up with some kind
of way to deal with it and that's what
that's what that book is all about so
read that book instead or read the power
in the glory Graham Greene you know the
protagonist the Christian protagonist in
that movie is a cowardly drunken
scoundrel who finally discovers his
faith and courage at the end after a
long and devastating journey but it's
it's it's it's real you know you feel
like this is a real person right so
there are plenty of great Christian
books that do what gods
not dead and other Christian movies
pretend to do and I would recommend that
you go to those instead all right and
they're there the movie Calvary was a
recent movie made not by a practicing
Christian but it's a film about a
small-town priest in modern Ireland
whose past during his flock of broken
and flawed sheep one of whom he has
informed in the confessional is planning
to kill him in revenge for the crimes
that the church has committed sex abuse
crimes not not crimes that this priest
committed but the church itself so in in
that movie is it has more truth and more
subtlety and more nuanced and more depth
in one scene then God's not dead could
muster collectively during its entire
two-hour runtime and as I said the
director is not even a practicing
Christian and he was able to do that all
right let's see here
let's move on all right okay I only
spent about thirty minutes on a movie
that came out five years ago you know
what we I think I'm going to skip emails
for the day I'll save these emails for
tomorrow because there's one other thing
I wanted to mention and I didn't want to
end the show without getting to this an
Australian politician Senator Fraser
Anning
made some pretty repulsive comments in
the wake of the mosque shootings in New
Zealand last week and you know he blamed
the shootings on on policies that allow
Muslims to enter the country in the
first place so there's really repulsive
Commons and then the next day he was in
front of reporters talking reporters and
this happened
now a lot of people on social media were
outraged that Anning assaulted a child
is what they said now the kid is 17 by
the way not a child and and you know the
people that were freaking out about this
these are the same people who most of
them who want 16 year olds to vote as we
talked about earlier so you can't say
that 16 year olds should vote and then
in the next breath say that a 17 year
old is just a helpless child if he's
just a helpless child who doesn't know
they're not supposed to break eggs over
people's heads then they don't belong in
the voting booth so anyway so he gets
punched in the face for egging this
senator as I said I don't support what
this guy said about the mosque shooting
but I totally support his right to punch
someone in the face when they smack him
in the head with an egg you break an egg
on a man's head and you get your nose
broken that it's a pretty simple formula
and it is a completely justified
responsibly well what was he supposed to
do was he supposed to say he gets hit in
the head with egg was he supposed to say
well yeah I deserve that you know what
you can hit me with another one turn the
other cheek right you know if someone
hits you in the head with an egg on one
side we had turn the other side it may
be in a perfect world that is you know
that that is how someone would respond
I'm sure that's how Jesus would have
responded but at the same time from the
perspective of the person smashing the
egg you have no right to not be punched
okay at that point you have the right to
be punched there's another way putting
it well once you once you do that it's
it's it's very simple I really well I'm
not gonna say I can't believe but I well
I guess I was even somehow this is how
naive I still am I was somehow actually
a little bit surprised that so many
people were criticizing this guy and not
the kid who the kid who broke an egg
over his head and you know what
I I could even be convinced that that
guy deserved to have an egg broken over
his head maybe he deserved it but the
problem is if you're the one who breaks
the egg you also deserve to get punched
so maybe this is a situation where both
sides got what they deserved and we can
just leave it at that we can leave it at
that kind of nice compromise that
kumbaya moment and we'll leave it there
for the day thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed